message our message of Hope optimism and
work in a partnership with others to get
things done
they voted for us to put extra money
into our Health Service and to help them
through the course 11 crisis they voted
for us to build more homes and to create
good quality jobs
I campaigned to lead a new executive as
a first Minister for all and I meant
what I said during that campaign
I will work every day as first Minister
designate to demonstrate through word
and deed a spirit of partnership and
respect towards everyone in our society
[Applause]
you see for politics to work it must be
inclusive
and that means the institutions of the
Good Friday agreement must work serve
and deliver fairly and equally for all
of our citizens and all of our
communities
my commitment is to make politics work
to make it work for everyone and to lead
an agenda for change through partnership
not division
I want to cooperate across party lines
and I want to deliver in government by
working with others who also want
progress
so our mission is to deliver on health
housing education and jobs we need to
put money into people's pockets to help
the deal with the cost of living crisis
we need to agree a budget and an extra 1
billion pounds into the Health Service
to reduce waiting lists to support
cancer and mental health services and
recruit and retain more doctors and
nurses
since day one after the election
shinpena stood ready to form a parishion
government we have been ready to work
with other parties and to serve all
communities it is so wrong that progress
on issues affecting the daily lives of
people are being put on hold because one
party one party refuses to accept the
Democratic outcome of last mayor's
Assembly election
[Applause]
now at any time that would be
unacceptable but in the middle of a
course to live in crisis it is really
disgraceful
as you all know the dup are using the
brexit protocol as cover not to enter
power sharing and
and you also know that the real reason
is because as an Irish nationalist I
will be at the helm as first Minister
and everybody knows it
[Applause]
last Friday character ministers were
forced from their departments leaving
civil servants in a really impossible
position and they're not expected to run
our essential public services with no
budget and no power is not good enough
simply not good enough
I want to finessar dash thank our
outgoing ministers Finance Minister
Connor Murphy communities Minister durji
hargi and infrastructure Minister John
odaud for their hard work on behalf of
the people
[Applause]
back and mayor people voted for change
yet the dup and the Tories offer only
disruption dysfunction and Chaos in
Belfast and in London
the British Secretary of State
repeatedly said that he would set a date
for an election should the dup feel to
restore parishion yet come the day come
they are he backed down and he failed to
do anything whatsoever and he's left the
people in limbo with his indecision and
his deathrun he needs a nice step out a
very definitive pathway on how we're
going to restore an executive instead of
feeling the instability and the
uncertainty
so if an election is called We Stand
ready we stand ready to refate a very
positive campaign a campaign to deliver
on the change that people voted for back
in May a campaign that's very much about
the future built on inclusivity
togetherness and respect
but in the meantime we cannot allow a
vacuum to be filled by threats of
violence or intimidation from loyalists
who want yesterday because let's be very
clear yesterday is not available to them
from The sardash Today I send all of our
solidarity to James Nesbitt and
Professor Colin Harvey of Queens
University
[Applause]
foreign
both have come under attack from senior
dep politicians and from some loyalists
but attack on them is an attack on
democracy and attack on all of us and it
must stop
earlier this week I was honored to
attend the funeral service of the late
Barnes my blood
I was privileged to join her beloved
family and all of those from the greater
Shankle Community who mourn the loss of
their greatest and deeply respected
community champion
this was a woman who was a mill worker a
trade unionist a community worker a
campaigner for social justice integrated
education and a founder of the women's
coalition
as first first Minister designated I
wanted to pay my respects and to go on
to the cycle because at the end of the
day we all lived together our battles
are all the same to make communities
better to offer families a secure life
to build a better future for our
children we have so so much more in
common than divides us
so reaching out the Honda friendship to
advance reconciliation is always going
to be our common ground
where together we can all build for the
future and to do so in a way that
reflects the diversity of our different
but equally legitimate allegiances
identities and aspirations
that is why back in September I attended
the funeral of Queen Elizabeth II I was
being respectful to all of those or
British and Eunice tradition from across
our society who felt her loss dearly
it reflects maturity as a new era of
change is ushered in where we can
celebrate our difference and our
diversity
last week there was a significant
development last week after Decades of
campaignan the Irish language was given
official recognition and law in the
north for the first time
[Applause]
will have guaranteed and protections and
law and the legal right to access Public
Services through Irish you see
resistance to rights has failed let's
not diminish each other's culture and
identity let's cherish each other's
difference
I am working to build a Sally not of
orange and green but a rainbow of colors
and multiculturalism which reflects who
we are and what we stand for today
since we last met some progress has also
been made on women's rights finally
women in the north will have right to
Modern compassionate health care when
they need it and those Services now need
to be put in place because a new
generation of women will not Abide a
repeat of the failures of the past
particularly whenever it comes to our
Healthcare
[Applause]
I want to address the issue of the
brexit protocol you see
it's no refutable fact that the protocol
is working
and the Jeffrey Donaldson is incapable
of accepting that is the case
he has now been rebuffed on numerous
occasions in the past week about his
misleading claims including
scaramongering about fatal medical cure
aharja
Jeffrey doesn't need a fact Jeffrey just
doesn't need a fact check he needs a
reality Jack
[Applause]
most working people businesses and the
key sectors that I made will want the
British government to urgently reach a
negotiated settlement with the EU around
the protocol the one certain day
instability so they can invest for the
future Taken full advantage over access
to the EU single market and the benefits
this brings to our economy
we welcome very much so the onset and
support of the White House and Congress
this was reaffirmed in a call between
President Biden and the British prime
minister last week we must defend and
protect the games of the Good Friday
agreement and the need to reach a
negotiated agreement with the European
Union
we welcome the new British prime
minister Richie sunick meeting with the
European commission president Usher
Wonderland and what we all want to see
now is a day to be done to make the
protocol work better
but for the avoidance of doubt neither
the assembly or the executive has any
manned yet a role in those negotiations
so to hold back parashar and in the
meantime is simply just to punish the
public it's Reckless and it natively
polarizes our society under politics so
my call my clear call today is for
London and for Brussels to propel the
protocol talks and for down and straight
to demonstrate the political will to get
a resolution
as for this dormant leaders
now is the time for a new Unity of
purpose and determination to deliver a
stable parture and Coalition that works
and more importantly that delivers
next April will Mark 25 years of peace
and the signing of the Good Friday
agreement
and would spend time reflect on the
transformation of our Island over the
last quarter Century but we will also
take the opportunity to look forward to
look forward and imagine what the future
can hold
we are now in the decade of opportunity
so friends let's embrace it and let's do
better for all the Oberlin again are sun
and fable
so we have work today
we have people to represent
the people want government
and all want and we want to change and I
I am firmly committed to both Shema
yelto knows Dave Carmelo
[Applause]